I think if I were Trump's press
secretary the one thing I would not want
to be is blindsided and surprised and
that's why I would never be I know
you're not a spokesman for the
conservative movement as a whole but do
you think conservatives maybe had some
branding issues over the years or I
think are actually I think actually are
melting away right now I mean I think
I'm probably evidence of it you know
when I go and you guys are all nice to
me and I can talk and debate and all
that good stuff but that for a long time
maybe just the word conservative it
sounds kind of stodgy and old and it's
like why would a young person want to be
conservative that that actually some of
that's actually changing right now
absolutely but it comes everything
cycles through the decades
you know National Review for me is my
dad I think was a subscriber since I was
a little kid I think he voted for
Goldwater I believe that's right and so
I cut I just grew up in that world on a
ranch and individual responsibility and
states rights that was super important
to all of us but sure certainly things
have changed for example I think
conservatives for a long time were
considered people who were against the
gay rights movement who were against gay
marriage and over time and not that long
a time if you think about it in history
uh protect that melted away
and so that I think allowed for people
to give conservatives in a different
look but part of that is what are you
comparing it to and if you are finding
that you are out of sorts with some of
the nonsense on the left then you might
take another look at conservatism and
you look at somebody like Dan Crenshaw
the congressman from Texas I did his
podcast this morning he's a younger
different kind of conservative and then
you see him on Saturday Night Live
responding with grace and humor to Pete
Davidson who had so you know casually
attacked him
mocking his war injury so there's a lot
of great opportunity for conservatives
but you know it's it's a challenge
especially at chin there's all these
different ways to communicate now so how
do you get to your ideas to be
persuasive for a larger amount of people
especially younger people that's a
challenge but I think it's I think it's
going better than some in the media
might think it is huh interesting
all right now I'm gonna ask you to put
the press secretary cap on so okay I'll
give you I'll give you two things here
one if you were Trump's press secretary
would you want more responsibility and
want him to rein it in a little bit a
little bit and two if you were Biden's
press secretary would you want him doing
these live streams that are in my humble
opinion coming off pretty terribly I
think if I were Trump's press secretary
the one thing I would not want to be is
blindsided and surprised and that's why
I would never be it's incredibly
difficult to think about knowing an
answer at 11 o'clock giving that answer
at 12 o'clock and having it undermined
at 12:06 p.m. but that is how he
operates for some people love it some
people think it's horrible the binding
question is a little bit more difficult
I don't know what I would do there in a
real fix right now because Joe Biden is
now the presumptive nominee he's gotten
no bang for that buck after Bernie
Sanders dropped out everybody's sort of
like yeah okay then Biden says I'm going
to start my VP search from like okay
well there's about 10 women that you
might consider so oh well I mean people
are just so zeroed in on appropriately
so the health of the nation and the
economic health of the nation and I
think that if Biden were to come out and
push too hard against President Trump
right now and criticize the commander in
chief in the time of a major that's just
a domestic crisis a global crisis it
would look like he was rooting for
failure for the country so he's got to
pick his spots very carefully and sharp
and I just don't know he's gonna be able
to do that do you sense though that some
in the media are rooting for the
collapse of the economy and just that
they viewed this as oh we we didn't get
Trump on Russia we didn't get Trump on
Ukraine impeachment I don't think so
that this you don't think so huh no I
don't I I don't I mean I consume a ton
of news I'm not naive to the biases but
there's a lot of problems out there I
mean I just like the Food lines it's
just the video you can see from overhead
a three-mile long car line to get food
in Miami a six mile long car line to get
food in San Antonio that those are just
facts those are those are happening uh
and I don't think that they root for the
failure they might root for President
Trump to lose but I don't think that
they root for failure for the people for
people I really don't yeah I hope you're
right I mean I see some people that are
pretty mainstream voices that it's
almost like they just want this thing to
continue well I mean that was doing that
financial crisis of 2008 right they were
like oh now anything but it was like
well the if you didn't shore up the
banks and you ended up with something
worse than the Great Depression what
would have been the better choice and
again presidents can't worry about that
President Trump has to again lift his
gait and not worry about the headline of
the day lift his gaze look out people
are gonna judge this for years and years
and years
forget about what they're gonna say
within the next 24 hours are you making
the best decisions with the information
you have at the time on behalf of the
nation and can you defend that decision
then that's a decision you should make
you should defend it as much as you can
and promote it whatever you need to do
but I wouldn't get so mired and oh
they're against me because I think
self-pity in politics is pretty pathetic
and pitiful and you just need to win the
just have to try harder to win the
arguments it just takes a lot more
effort that's why I always tell
companies if you think you're gonna have
some problems always hire somebody
that's worked in Republican politics or
communications because
guaranteed they've had to work harder
they've been through it once or twice
yeah yeah do you think do you think that
Trump those sort of needs that in a way
like it's almost like him and Jim Acosta
are just like a match made in hell sort
of thing like CNN needs it for eyeballs
and Trump needs it because that's like
sort of what gives him juice so their
relationship yeah yeah the symbiotic
relationship they feed off of each other
but I was watching a press conference
recently and I could I heard myself
saying that's a ridiculous question
that's a dumb question that but but look
our founding fathers were really really
brilliant and the First Amendment was
first for a reason
because it's most important so we have
to safeguard it and if they want to ask
stupid questions
that's so be it all right I got two more
for you and then I know you got to go do
the five because you do have it you do
have a day job too so one I've been
joking for about two years people always
say to me you know Dave do you want or
get are you gonna get into politics and
I always say no but if Ben Shapiro
becomes president I will be his press
secretary is that crazy thing for me to
say do you think that's a crazy thing
I've never said this out loud but I told
Ben Shapiro if he becomes president I
would come be his chief of staff well I
already thrilled to work with you so
maybe we are putting the pieces together
here just to see you thought you were
gonna get out and they pull you right
back
that's so funny I never said that out
loud that's true all right so that aside
now the really the most important thing
where is Jasper and tell us about Jasper
and let's see Jasper so Jasper is eight
years old he's here Jasper hey can you
come here come come Clyde Clyde always
gets shy when I'm on your show so let's
see if Jasper can show them up come on
since he was a kid since he was born
come say hi to your people come on
up there we go this is Jasper oh look at
this wait what now you gonna do it come
on look at Jasper he's gorgeous she's
eight years old come on Clyde what are
you doing I'm crazy come on there we go
all right we're having things I found
Dave is that no come stay that dogs are
a great equalizer there's no politics at
the dog park for me we all love our dogs
and they give us a lot of joy and you
know whatever love you give them you get
back five times in return I'm so so glad
that you two plunge back in and rescued
Clyde it makes me happy for you and your
household and for Clyde in particular
and I told you literally I had him like
it was like the second day I had him and
I'm walking him down the street and this
guy my neighbor for years who I've seen
for years but never said hello to who's
oh that's Clyde I just saw him on Dana
Perino show so we're making the world a
better place I go I love that I really
know you yeah same here well thanks for
thanks for doing good work in in the
midst of this craziness and showing
people that you can be human and still
like politics and and taking good care
of Jasper so have a great day if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell